yes really grim uh reports about the
potential for more mass graves there's
been some new satellite imagery released
by a u.s satellite company which seems
to show the digging of of masquerade of
a mass grave in a village just outside
mariupol and yes like you said the mayor
of the city believing that russia is
trying to hide its crimes picking up
bodies from the street and then dumping
them in these mass graves we've seen
mass graves
outside of kiev during the time that
russian forces were in control of towns
and villages there so you can only
imagine what might be happening in mario
paul i spoke to the mayor actually a few
days ago and he said that anything that
happened in places like butcher
times that by 10 and that's what you've
got in mario paul there is still this
steel works in the city where ukrainian
fighters are holding out where there are
there are hundreds of wounded fighters
as well unable to get medical attention
and also civilians believed to be in
that steel works actually uh putin wants
to destroy ukraine and wants to kill all
ukrainians we see it in
his speeches
we see in it in the speeches of his
authorities but when i as a prosecutor
should go to the court i should come
with evidences i will give you evidences
when i will have access to this
territory i think that it is strategy of
the
chief of commander
because we see the same strategy in
other countries actually when they come
to cities and when cities don't want to
capitulate
they have plan a cities should
capitulate if cities are not capital uh
wasn't capillary territory it means
that plan b
to scare this population for maximum
kill
rape or
torture and other and other brutal
things it is strategic
you